now here's a quick fact check for you
any time biden the democrats and their
servants in the media talk about the
disastrous biden economy these days i've
noticed they all point to the low
unemployment rate yeah it's 93.9 percent
and the fact that they've created six
million jobs the highest in the first
year of any presidency in history
earlier this week they even tried to
shore up their argument with this
totally misleading graphic after biden's
embarrassing press conference so first
of all those six million jobs biden
created it is obviously the rebound from
the democrats lockdowns and forced
business closures and why did america
have that rebound obviously because
president trump got the vaccines
delivered in record time what biden and
the democrats have done by contrast is
put brakes on the trump rebound by
paying people not to work raising energy
costs and throwing people out of the
workforce with their anti-science
unjustified mandates and so as a result
even with a low unemployment number
there are still nearly three million
americans out of the workforce compared
to what we had with trump just before
the pandemic in fact i looked up the
historic data on labor participation the
size of the american workforce as a
proportion of the working age population
and here it is under biden as of last
month we're down to a labor
participation rate of just 61.9 percent
apart from at the height of the pandemic
economic shutdown that's the lowest
since the dregs of the jimmy carter
stagnation and malaise in february 1977
so this great booming economy biden and
all the rest of the muppets are trying
to brag about now has the worst
inflation in 39 years and the worst job
market in 45 years yeah i guess that is
historic historically bad hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else